I was like walking by and like this lady
comes to me she's like oh you know your
aura is really interesting oh here we go
oh really and I think I think at this
point too like I already just had like a
fresh like hair color dye on there so I
was like did she did she's like pick up
on me because it got colored hair and
now she's like chilling in the grocery
store and she's like yeah like there's
something really interesting going on I
was like oh yeah tell me about it she's
like here's my card you can reach to me
if you want a whole like reading and I
was like oh that's a good lead you
should flip it on her you should out
psychic her be like you know what lady I
kind of read you two and your whole aura
yes yes
you are surrounded with so much bad
energy like I know she would have been
like you think so like